okay I'd like to go ahead and open up
our exec sessions for today with a a
note first for the committee
members um I have been working on a
schedule for the rest of this uh session
here and uh we will be uh not meeting at
all next week so it will be a total
break we all need it I need it
um on on on starting though when we come
back on March
4th we're going to be
hearing five bills on that day and I I
I'll give them to you I don't know I got
them written down here I don't know
specifically the order which we're going
to be doing but they we're going to be
doing them on that dat
1650 and
1610 those will be heard on
Monday just in case somebody wanted to
take another couple days on their
vacation break we're not executing on
the
Monday Mr chair no par me time please
start time most likely we'll be starting
early probably either 9:15 something
like that I'll be looking at this if we
want to go a little bit in the afternoon
I could start at 9:30 that there's
nothing solid down here yet um on
Tuesday March
5th we're going to start having bills
hitting Senate
education and folks are going to want to
go testify there or testify in another
Senate Bill and we're going to be trying
to exec so I also have five bills for
hearing on that Tuesday so there will be
no conflicts with somebody if they want
to get up and go down to Senator Wards
committee and testify in behalf of some
bill so on that day we're going to be
105105 we're going to be dealing with
hr30 so between Monday and Tuesday we'll
be dealing with 10 hearings we have 10
hearings left we've done all 107
hearings and these are the last 10 of
that
107 going on to the next day which is
Wednesday March 6th we're going to start
executing and of the bills of the 107
bills there are a total of 35 bills we
have not yet
exec so I'm going to be listing and that
includes the eight bills we have for
today so if you took it out it' be 27
left but we're not going to hit all
eight today so there's going to be some
that put on hold and they will carry
forward but on March 6th I'll just read
off these numbers which you're going to
see up here in the calendar it doesn't
mean we have to do them on that
particular day but we will be addressing
most of them as many as possible
1476 15
1691 and
hr30 we're not obviously going to get
all on that date so what we're going to
do that session will continue
on March
Friday seeing the following week as the
week bills have to be out of here and
the following week we only have two and
a half days and then everything has to
be
done we're doing pardon
me done with all 107 bills so basically
what we're going to be doing then on
Monday March
11th we're going to be carrying forward
executive sessions which we may have but
I also have set up at the beginning
there will be I understand a non-gain
Amendment for
10:15 so we'll have a hearing on that
then we're going to go into a work
session for the rest of that morning
that's on Monday we're going to be
dealing with because there's a number of
people here that have not had the
wonderful experience of talking about
merging Cooperative school
districts uh how to uh um apportionment
methods for these um how you seat
vacancies all that we have bills Rel to
all this but we're going to have to
we're going to have um a meeting that a
lot of these agreements for co-ops were
written back in 16 16 19 might just well
be 19 1959
1960s yeah and there's several co-ops
that don't even have agreements and so
all this comes into play and and I think
everybody should have that background
information following that we will go
into executive sessions in the afternoon
on the 11th and we will be dealing with
perhaps some of those Coop bills um and
other bills which might be hanging loose
that we haven't gotten to and then on
the Tuesday following on 3:12 we'll
clean up any remaining uh uh bills
there's going to be one bill which we're
going to probably have on that
particular day and that's the one
dealing with the consolidation of higher
education we're waiting for a task force
that's meeting on the Fridays we meet
this Friday next Friday um and then that
other Friday uh in the afternoon and
we're trying to get some kind of
understanding do they need some help
from the legislature in any areas of
statute that may be needed and I don't
have a hot clue on that right now but
we're holding that bill right to the end
so that it'll be available for that
particular task force so that's where
we're going um we're coming down to the
end here as you can see we have when we
come back the Monday Tuesday Wednesday
and Friday and then we have the Monday
Tuesday basically to get things done on
that Wednesday all reports have to be in
by noon so that means there's going to
be a lot of writing of committee reports
and getting that done and we leave the
morning of that Wednesday open in case
there is something that comes up we have
to attend to it's going to be busy but
if we want that break at the end of the
month here we're going to have to really
address these things as I mentioned here
are there any questions on
that fun and games that means we'll be
able to take the solar eclipse day off
right
ail that's April now that's that I would
hope you get that off anyways because
that's that's not even in March I know
it's April yeah but but that mean but
the point is we'll be done so that we'll
be able to take that is it on what day
what it's a Monday yeah yeah it should
be good depending upon too what we're
getting from the Senate and I don't know
what the Senate is sending us I had a
talk last night with folks upstairs
about that and we're just waiting and
there well so you can be inside here and
you're not going to ruin your retinas I
okay yeah I I we're not gonna have a
meeting that day so don't worry
so I'd just like to yank your chain a
little bit I know well I was yanking
yours when I said it okay so with that
let's get on to the bills which we have
today and is we walk down the docket
here we have um do you have the
amendment uh on okay 1312 so we're going
to hit 1312 this is requiring parental
notification of student health and
well-being and certain curricula so
up
thank
you
one
just okay I'd like to uh recognize
represent cordelli for a motion please
uh thank you U Mr chairman I would move
uh on to
pass was there a
representative leus okay uh
representative uh motion made by
represent cordelli and second by rep uh
representative leus uh we're dealing
with HB 1312 represent cordelli you
recognized to speak to your
motion uh thank you
um yes this bill um deals with uh uh a
couple of things um in the top
section one um it deals with um uh the
um statute related to uh materials that
should be made available to parents in
advance and the ability for parents uh
to opt out of those
amendment which uh I just imp passing
around is amendment
0774 h
um and I would move ought to pass on
that Amendment okay let's stop right
there so we have an amendment in front
of us on
07748 there is a motion made by
represent cordelli to uh add amendment
that Amendment to the oop pass motion is
there a second represent Lea seconds the
motion representa Cordell you're welcome
to speak to the
amendment uh thank you um Mr chairman um
this um paragraph
um relates to policies and procedures
that are to be set up uh by a district
and it said specifically that in the
original bill that a district may not
adopt a policy or procedure that
prohibited School District Personnel
from notifying a parent about their
students mental emotional uh physical
health Etc uh
and the amendment changes that um to not
removes notifying the parent and changes
it to uh cannot prohibit Personnel from
answering questions from a parent about
those subject
areas Is there further discussion on the
amendment represent
whitcock thank you
chairman just is for you explained that
with what that means the last part of
the statement about not prohibit I was
kind of confused
there what you just said um uh basically
um School personnel has to be honest
with parents if they answer if they ask
a question about any one of those
subject areas um they have to uh uh
truthfully answer the parent um about
the
situation
um just that um
uh as has been debated um on parents
Rights bill um we don't want um School
Personnel keeping SE keeping secrets um
from parents we want uh School Personnel
to always be truthful with
parents follow up please yes thank you
Mr chair um I'm looking particularly at
the part that you
didn't uh say in lines n and 10 and your
Amendment uh qu ell um and it concerns
me about the fact that you're also added
in there you forgot to talk about the
sexuality of chance services will have
the eff of you didn't mention that but
that's okay it's here if they encourage
a student to withhold from parents such
information so basically you're you're
um if a youngster is
um uh
questioning their mental health or
questioning their uh gender identity or
question their feelings you're saying
that they probably shouldn't encourage a
student to go to counseling or talk to
someone else because they have the
effect of encouraging student withold
information go see a professional
because that's does that that am I
reading that
right um it's just indicating that if a
parent contacts the school personnel and
asks about um the students um health or
sexuality or changes in related
Services um then the uh School personnel
has to tell uh the parent what's going
on follow Mr Cher final question yes
thank you well I don't read it that way
and I'll tell you why because when you
look at in n 10 it says or encourage you
have the effect of encouraging a student
to withhold from a parent such
information that's not the school
teacher that's at telling the youngster
so once again if the school professional
is saying you know what you may want to
go talk to a guidance cons or mental
health counselor or a crisis counselor
um before see that's what that says you
can't you shouldn't do you can't
encourage that right right School
Personnel should not be encouraging uh
students to withhold information from
parents this is but that's the impact is
you if I may Mr
chair thank you the impact of that is
you're not allowing School
professionally trained Personnel to tell
a student you know what you may want to
go see a counseling you may want do this
maybe this is your first
step I I disagree with that
interpretation I I think it's uh just
saying um School Personnel should not be
telling uh student don't tell your
parent about this it doesn't say that so
not encourage to go see that says no
counseling not encourag wait represent
leus thank you Mr chair I'm done thank
you uh on lines on lines 12 through 15
is that the exception clause for uh a
teacher that's contacted Health and
Human Services or DCF regarding a
youngster right um they do not have to
uh discuss that with the parent if there
is uh the belief as is stated in here
reasonably prudent person would feel
that there was the possibility of uh
leus not seeing anything
about not being able to tell a kid they
can't go to counseling it says they
can't discourage or prohibit parent
notification of oh no wait it's the one
before that or that encourage or have
the effect of encouraging a student to
withhold from a parent such information
I don't see where it
says that they can't tell them they
pardon me she asking me a question go
for the chair who who is the question to
the committee no uh rep Woodcock because
he had made a statement that I'm not
finding do you want to respond to that
you don't have to yes thank you Mr chair
uh my point is representative Le is that
that point about having the effect of
ENC caring the student withhold from a
parent such information that would say
to me if I say to uh my student here
miss miss Heath you know what maybe you
want to see the guidance before you talk
to your parents or maybe you want to do
this maybe want to get some more
information before that would be the
exact same thing encouraging unless tell
with hold I'm just saying that say you
can't do that so I'd be I'm very L about
that we have professionally trained
staff in the schools for that exact
purpose thank you Mr chair represent
Damon thank you Mr
chair I just want to state that I
understand and please correct me if I'm
wrong
the premise of this bill to suggest that
currently School staff are trying to
withhold information from parents and I
vigorously protest that lack of trust in
our trained Educators who have the
well-being of students first and
foremost represent
beler thank you Mr chair and
um I'm not quite sure on the specific
interpretation but I would like to just
note generally that it is entirely
inappropriate for school Personnel to be
directing students to health care
services including mental health
services without roping the parents into
that conversation thank
you representative kiscaden thank you Mr
chair I have two questions if I may um
do you know what the opinion of the
social work workers a therapist and the
health organizations are in regards to
forward are you addressing I'm asking
that question to
whoever's presented this
bill I I'm just putting in an amendment
to the original
Bill second question yes can you give us
an example of a direct violation that
bill uh I I'm not one of the sponsors I
point did you have another question
represent
cascad well we have two members on the
committee that are co-sponsored so I
didn't know if they had the answers
that's all thank thank you Mr chair I
just wanted to do the best I can to to
answer that particular question because
my district in my town Wakefield we have
a Schoolboard policy that
explicitly
instructs uh professionals and Educators
to not be honest with parents about
these kinds of
criteria Mr chair could I just have the
reference to that please yes just what
policy that policy from that District
what is it I'll up thank
you represent Tanner thank you I
actually have two questions one is um
what's a student support
form and also um how would this be
enforced what how can you what would you
see this as being How
would how would this actually work out I
guess it just seems so cumbersome if if
I'm coaching somebody sprains their
ankle uh and I say to the kid uh you
know that's that that's looks like a
pretty bad sprain you might go want to
go see the athletic director or the a um
athletic trainer uh before you go home
uh rather than immediately going and
calling the parent and saying you know
uh they sprained their ankle uh you know
Rush here usually it's a minor sprain um
would it violate this and and how would
you as a teacher know whether you're
violating this or not or how would the
supervisor or
whatever student support for First
Student support for representa
cordelli thank you I I think if you're
um dealing with an injury to a student
um I think a parent would expect that uh
the school is going to act to have that
uh injury taken care of um but I I think
at the same point um if there is an
injury to a student that the school
should be contacting the parent about
that
situation what about a student support
form do you know what that is it's in
line seven yeah that's the question is
uh on line seven there's reference to a
support forms
uh while student support forms um trying
to get a definition what's meant by that
yeah yeah that that is in the original
bill yeah yeah I mean that's in the
original Law because the original bill
is changing what's involed and that's
no it's it's a new paragraph it's all
new it's all
new yeah further questions on the
amendment we're looking
at section two
here 9e yes representative Cornell so I
I don't understand Lance I guess I do
understand Lance 12 through 15 would
that mean that Isa Guan counselor who
have a relationship with the student and
have known the family for the past 15
years if I know that telling the parents
is going to result in something
happening to that child I have to tell
them
anyway is that is that what that says I
says so I would not have to tell
them right a reasonably prudent person
who believes that it would uh disclosure
would result in abandonment neglect or
abuse yeah what's the definition of a
person uh I think that there are many um
legal terms that um we have in statute
uh uh Beyond A Reasonable Doubt Etc um
that uh have
um a common understanding I I I don't
think that um a definition is um
required here
um if if there is any action um uh I I
think that uh um it could be determined
later if the person was acting prudently
actions further discussion represent
Damon thank
you so representative corellia if you
could please expand on what you just
said I'm not clear how
a guidance counselor or other school
staff would
be uh
clear what reasonably prudent is because
as I heard what you just said it would
be determined after the fact I mean how
is that staff person supposed to proceed
know I'll leave it the fact that um a
reasonbly pren parent I think if they
think that there is going to be abuse or
neglect because of disclosure of
information um they would not have to do
it uh or make that
disclosure
um uh you know I I think U you know what
is do we need a definition of uh Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt um anything like that
um you I I don't
see
this I'm just trying myself to look up
if there's in the annotated versions
here under 169 C3 whether there's any
reference to this language
f
is there any further discussion
representative Heath thank you Mr chair
just a simple question of of um
representative cordelli um
is it
anticipated that this information this
bill would apply to children attending
um private or sectarian schools uh for
which they receive an EFA would this
well
um I have to go back and look at the uh
original
statutes um related to uh school
districts um but this specifically says
district yes represent Miler thank you
Mr chair I think one of the concerns I
have about this this would fall under
the category of it's in the eye of the
beholder and the vagueness of it
because uh even if you look at the issue
of the prudent person
standard the prudent person standard is
also subject to
interpretation and what I might think
was
prudent another might not perceive as
being
prudent and so this is I think this
whole
section uh is is uh you know
subjective and what one person might
think is okay another person may not
think is okay and that's that's the
problem I'm having with this right here
here because I I do think that uh that
school Personnel uh I think they do try
to be prudent I think they do try to be
uh direct uh in protecting the privacy
of students Etc as well as dealing with
parents and this language I think just
kind of muddies that water of
interpretation of U what would be the
standard that would cause a School
employee uh to come under suspect based
upon a decision that they might make at
that particular time that they're
involved
in yes represent cordelli thank you I I
think that the term reasonable is used
throughout our statutes um in relation
to child custody um Etc um and even in
169 C3 um under Guardian it talks about
um reasonable visitation rights so you
know do we want to go back and uh put in
a definition of what visible uh excuse
me reasonable visitation rights are so
reasonable is used throughout our
statutes perent Cornell yeah I
reasonably prudent person is in both the
amendment and the original bill but in
this paragraph the only change in this
amendment is on line seven and 8 it says
answering questions from a parent and on
line 22 and 2 three in the original bill
it says notifying a parent so the only
difference in the entire amendment is
those two words correct uh pretty
much further discussion represent
cordello thank you Mr chair so I was
just looking up prudent because you know
the word I know what it means sort of
you know I'm looking up cautious
sensible I would hope that anyone who
works in a school who is supposed to
have the best interest of the children
uh in mind would fit be hired to fit
that criteria of being a reasonably
prudent
person represent leus then represent
Woodcock all throughout
law we write General law we don't write
specific law because we can't think of
every specific and if we write very
specific law then they tends to be
interpreted as if we didn't include it
in the list it's not
included and if you look at most of the
laws on the book they are General and
there are General understandings of what
things
like I just lost the word again um re
without a you know Reasonable Doubt
various things like that we go through
all the time it's it we are told we are
to write laws
generally because we can't think of
every single specific and so we not we
can't say well what exactly so we have a
list of what does reasonably prudent
mean what is reasonably prudent what is
not reasonably prudent I mean we don't
write law that way we write law that's
General that gets interpreted and that's
that's what we do throughout law so I
don't know why
suddenly reasonably prudent is well too
vague when it's as specific as any of
the rest of the
things per woodcock thank you chairman
but um I'd like to go back to
representative Cornell's statement uh uh
as a counselor and going back to uh line
14 and the determination that
representative cordelli made about the
disclosure uh where it says uh would
result in abuse uh if Miss Heath if she
doesn't mind me using her again comes up
to me and says Mr Woodcock you know what
um this is happening to me or I may be
pregnant or I think I may be gay or
whatever it happens to be but please you
can't tell my parents yet CU they'll
kill me they're going to beat me up my
father beat me they not going to allow
that in the house I'm a good whatever I
happen to be so I would say based on
this then you know what your have best
health mental health and lack opport
lack of abuse to me to keep my mouth
shut and it seem like that sort of uh
the opposite of what this is saying um
So based on that with with that def that
situation be correct representative
cordelli they would not have to tell the
parent then or inform the parent because
the youngster young young my young
12-year-old friend here miss Heath would
be petrified of being beaten when they
went
home uh I think that that would waren
additional discussion with the student
um I think uh it would uh involve
knowing uh the student and uh to some
extent uh their history um if this
student has been in in the school or in
the class before there might be some
indications of uh some prior family
problems so I think that you know the
question you ask um is a requires
broader um information um in making that
determination and I think that schools
should probably have
it seemed pretty simple to me if I may
it seemed pretty simple I thought my
answer was pretty simple okay well it
sort of beat around the bush didn't
answer it okay let's go through
rep and
dry thank you Mr
chairman so I'm in the child protection
act section 169 C3 with all the
definitions and throughout these
definitions there four pages of
definitions are things like compelling
reason uh founded report versus
unfounded report versus unfounded but
with reasonable concern so there's there
are things that are not defined
specifically uh but have that kind of
there is a A Reasonable Doubt I think
that they they this is the permeates
this that you're looking at your good
judgment and acting in good faith and I
think that that's pretty reasonable
interpretation of what's looking for in
the child abuse and child protection act
I I'd like to note that in the child
protection act the word suspected is
used you're required you're mandated to
report if you
suspect abuse neglect
so uh in from that line could read from
apparent if it is suspected that
disclosure would result in abuse abandon
or neglect um there there there's number
of ways I think what what representative
Cordell is saying is absolutely so that
you know if you believe if a reasonable
person believes that this could result
from communicating with that parent that
there will be further abuse and neglect
and of the child obviously you don't
want to communicate with the parent on
that but on most situations the parent
should be informed I don't think most
parents would do that but there are some
that
do so suspected is is is a word that's
used right on page 166 of your books is
the primary purpose of this chapter
through mandatory reporting of suspected
instances of child abuse or
neglect and that's where you report to
proper agency represent
Woodcock but 51a that's a mandated
report which we all are in schools that
is after the fact that's after the fact
when we suspect that the a youngster has
been abused or neglect whatever happens
to be it's after the fact is not prior
to the fact this talks about prior to
further questions yes represent Hanner
or or or discussion yes um so I I think
uh this this amendment and and this
second paragraph of the bill um is
something that
that should reside in local control it
should be a local Schoolboard policy um
and handled at a at a local level uh
parent complaint should be handled first
at the school level or with the teacher
and then at the school level and then at
the school board and so on and when
there is um something like this which is
which is vague it's very hard as uh
representative Miler said it's in the
eye of the beholder uh you know one
person the parent might feel one way the
school might feel the other way um I
think that uh resolving that or or just
even even having this on on the books is
is
like not necessary number one because it
because schools deal with with um this
issue all the time and number two I
think that um there's no no way
to I mean I can I can see this part
being abused or or being so vague that
it could it could pop up at any time and
and when representative leus said that
we want vague law so that we cover
everything we also want laws that are
able to be enforced that have a
reasonable uh process to it um and and
this doesn't have it it it it usurps at
the at the state level something that
that happens at the local level and
should be taken care of at the local
level um and there are processes that if
if a person is unsatisfied with how it's
done at the local they can they can go
about that perap cordellia do you have
um further information just in terms of
this whole reasonably thing um you know
we we've had um representative dry read
from uh current statute um you just
referred representative tner to a re
reasonable process I I don't know about
you know I'm not sure what a reasonable
process is what might be a reasonable
process to me might be different than a
reasonable process to representative
drive so um you know reasonable is a
term that is used throughout our
statutes and I think to try and nitpick
it on uh line
14 um is um really not uh addressing
what we're trying to accomplish with
this which is simply um putting in place
statute that um
requires uh schools to be honest with
parents um we've heard about that in
Prior legislation in the past couple of
terms um uh representative Bel just
mentioned about a policy um that has
been common in many school
districts um that's still evidently in
district any further discussion on the
amendment represent Belcher thank you Mr
chair the reference was requested and I
would like to provide it I had to go
through dozens of different PDFs to find
the correct one SAU 101 jbab transgender
and gender non-conforming student
policy section three guidance a privacy
the board recognizes a student's right
to keep private one's transgender status
or gender non-conforming presentation at
school information about a students
transgender status legal name or gender
assigned at Birth may also constitute
confidential information School
Personnel should not disclose
information that may reveal a student's
transgender status or gender
non-conforming presentation to others
including parents moving on to paragraph
three when contacting the parent or
guardian of a transgender or gender
nonconforming student School Personnel
should use the student's legal name and
the pronoun corresponding to the
student's gender assigned at Birth
unless the student has specified
otherwise thank you further questions or
discussion on the am represent Tanner
Tanny Terry Terry excuse me thanks Paul
um Mr chairman I uh as a new member of
the committee I I appreciate the wide
ranging uh discussion here with respect
to the entire language contained within
this uh Amendment but I but I I I
believe that I'm understanding that the
the language uh is uh essentially
duplicative of the language that's in
the underlying Bill except because no
one appeared to correct representative
Cornell that the substantive change here
is with respect to notification or of
parents or asking or or responding to uh
a question that is that is posed by a
parent and that's the real Focus here of
this amendment um the burden therefore
being upon the parent to ask the
question and then the responsibility of
the school Personnel to respond openly
and honestly to that question um but
with the exceptions that are noted uh
that we've discussed uh that um that
we've discussed um so there the change
here is from placing the burden upon
School Personnel to take the
initiative to notify parents of any of
these concerns that are uh specified in
the in the paragraph and in the bill to
uh answering honestly and forthrightly a
question that's posed by a parent and
and believing that the primary
relationship is between the parent and
the child and
not the school and the child and because
the school effectively is acting in
local parentice and is in an effective
trust relationship with the parents it
seems to me that this is an eminently
good sense and appropriate change to
make because of that relationship thank
you thank you further further discussion
are we getting there represent dry thank
you I'm just I'm going to go back to the
child protective act again and just say
that the primary purpose in the first
paragraph is to protect the safety of
the child take such action as may be
necessary to prevent the abuse or
neglect of children but I want to take
this back to the end here and say that
we're not asking a reasonably prudent
person to disclose or not we're asking
the school district to adopt or or
permitting the school district to about
policies that would permit a school
Personnel to withhold such information
so it would be incumbent on the school
district to make the policy that defined
what reasonably prudent means okay I
think we've had enough discussion on
this right now we're going to move ahead
we got a motion on the floor it's uh the
amendment which we're speaking to is
0774 H uh the motion is for OTP on the
amendment uh represent
would you please call the role Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Terry yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Cora yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no representative
Heath no Representative wooda no
representative Hall no representative
Lane no Representative cascaden no
representative uh Damon sorry
yes and chairman lad yes excuse me no
yes excuse
me okay I was a little confused I didn't
days correct what did you have 11 11
okay could I
said okay bre Cordell yes I would like
to make a subsequent motion of ought to
pass as amended with amendment
0774 is there a
second we have a motion on the table to
approve 1312 with Amendment 00
0774 made by representa cordelli and
second by represent
beler further discussion not seeing
rooll vice chairman cordelli yes
representative luckus yes representative
Terry yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
cortiella yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative Lane no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
n is there a subsequent motion represent
itl is there a second represent Tanner
yes motion made by represent Miler
second by represent Tanner to itl the
bill
1312 further discussion on that from the
maker of the motion thank you second not
seeing any other further discussion from
the committee Madam clerk please call
the rule voice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Terry no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
cell no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Lane yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
y who will be doing the
report pardon
mean represent Tanner will be doing the
report for itl and for OTP be represent
1671 school officials right of action
one you get a copy
yeah
am
okay uh we've had discussion on this
bill prior to this uh so I'm not going
to take any recommendations for motion
right now I'd like to have repres Tanner
if you would please you have two
amendments that you brought forward on
this bill one is 0499 H and this one
right just recently passed out 080 1 H
could you please explain uh the
differences and what they're they're
about so
99 um
was determined to be non-
gerain and um it
was a bill that was that referenced um a
totally new section of of law than the
original Bill and that's why I believe
it was ruled J non Germain this this one
um references the exact section that
16 uh 71 originally was set to um go to
uh which is 193 colon 40 uh section 4
and it's and it starts out the same as
as section 4 in the book violations of
this section by any educator shall and
not is placed in there be considered a
violation of the educator code of
conduct and uh then it has the remaining
language okay so it's replacing the
whole
bill so this is the bill right and it
just speaks to section four of 193 colon
40 um which was where the original Bill
uh spoke to
that
so just in response you're no longer
referencing the code ethics you're
referencing the code of conduct which is
a separate section within the
professional codes which was which was
um
19340 is there any other discussion
before I take any action here yes
represent
belard yes I I just wanted to I I guess
help clarify something because I'm not
I'm not sure how this works reading it
there seems to be an issue here to me
that this seems to be saying that if the
if an educator violates the code of
conduct potentially even in an egregious
way that would generally justify
employment action or a lawsuit based on
any number of factors that this would
essentially provide them with immunity
for that by saying that because it's in
the code of conduct it cannot be used
against
them well the confusion I have just
so the reference to a basis for civil
liability is mentioned under the code of
ethics not under the code of conduct but
now we're seeing that
switch and now being under the code of
conduct and this code was developed with
a lot of hard work as a result of a task
force of Educators that came together
and worked with the Department of
Education to come up with this that came
back for approval from jelar and it was
initiated initially by legislation so I
I see this as a significant change from
what we have in place represent beler
thank you and if I may respond just to
add on to what you were just saying um
there there would be a major difference
between something existing within a code
of conduct that suggests this should not
be used for employment action or or
civil liability which is a suggestion
within the code of conduct but it would
be an entirely different thing to
enshrine that in law where it may in
fact provide a total immunity for
that yes yeah I think it's it's
important to note that uh to embellish a
bit what chairman lad
said that when this when the code of
conduct was was
created it was created not to be a an
abusive
system uh that there are other there are
other channels to challenge employee
Behavior Etc but that the code was
basically to provide a
guideline for how a professional
employee professional Educators conduct
themselves but it was never meant to be
a an abusive system or a liability
system uh and I think what uh
representative Court Tanner is trying to
do here is to basically cify the
original intent of that code which was
not to be an abusive kind of a system
like am I correct Mr chair as you as you
I would kindly disagree with you that um
the code of conduct is totally separate
apart from the code of
ethics and there's a Code of Conduct
that
references how it's to be used and a
process for where you have either a
reprimand a suspension or the loss of
your teaching credential so it's to
address those issues which are basically
uh where they're diverging from uh
everything that a teacher's credential
speaks
to so I I I I'm I'm a little confused
here as to why we're now bringing over
this basis for civil liability and all
that when it doesn't speak to in the Cod
of conduct to that at all it's speaking
to that under the code of
ethics and the code of ethics is not
what we use to administer the results
which can occur from the code of conduct
the we've been told over and over by the
ass professional Teachers Association
that they're
separate now we're trying
to bring it together and I I think
that's
um uh to me that's not acceptable yes so
so uh when we look at that section four
um on page 540 in our blue books it's
the the original statement was violation
of this section by an educator shall be
considered a violation of the educator
code of conduct that justifies
disciplinary sanction by the State Board
of
Education my amendment is addressing the
fact
that the the original intent of the code
of conduct was never to be
used for disciplinary sanction for
things like
curriculum
pedagogy it was for
um if you want High crimes and
misdemeanors it was for uh the the types
of uh violations that were considered
extreme and that therefore that's why it
speaks to the code of conduct in this
particular Amendment because it's a
reference to this particular law and
it's a reference to
um or my attempt that this code was made
under good faith and it's being used now
as quote unquote
punishment a punishment factor and I
don't think that was the original intent
of the code and I don't think it's
appropriate to have it in this
particular
section further discussion represent
leus I don't have my code book with
me and so I have a question as
to the section that talks
about
[Music]
um suspension Etc is that under conduct
or
ethics conduct conduct so then if we've
said it should not be the basis for
employment action but that is employment
action that's under the code of conduct
so we are by if we adopt this
negating the code of conduct as far as
what's in
correct are you asking me or I think I
was asking you because you had the
because you had the book in front of
you but somebody else anybody else who
the Cod of conduct is
to deal with
unprofessional conduct right by the
educator in terms of use of Technology
of use with students these categorical
areas are responsibility to students
responsibility to school and Community
responsibility in use of
technology um these are all within
ed510 so uh it's all identified there uh
whereas the code of ethics is is not
dealing with that unprofessional conduct
it's dealing with what is
professional it's the opposite and so I
I think that you know and when we say in
the code of ethics the code of ethics
establishes a guidance for all School
personnel and is not intended to be a
basis for civil liability nor is it
designed to be a basis for employment
action but that's the it's guidance for
educators what you expect with that then
on the other side we spell out what is
unprofessional conduct where then there
is ramification which occurs either you
you're you're reprimanded you're
suspended or you lose your teaching
credential
I don't think you can mix and match
those things that's without you know
this was put together back I I remember
the year we put the legislation forward
but this was put together and it there's
a a prefixing letter here January
2019 which was completed and sent and
part of this right by Christine Brennan
and uh commissioner edbl and it was a
result of teachers working many many
many months on on putting this all
together I don't think that it's wise to
as a result of an amendment here to all
of a sudden do a
switch Yeah that's so so ethics says
should not be the basis but conduct is
the basis and so if we pass this we're
saying conduct sh shall not be the basis
for that either and so we're negating
any um action I
represent
cordelli uh thank you Mr uh chairman um
under the code of conduct Ed
.01 uh d uh specify unprofessional
conduct which justifies disciplinary
sanctions against credential
holders um reading further into
5102 um unprofessional conduct shall
include clude but be not limited to
discrimination against the student as is
specified in 354 a A1 um it goes on then
uh the same for um community members who
might be U on school property
discrimination against them so I think
that um this amendment would negate all
that um and be contrary to uh what is
conduct repr
belshire thank you Mr chair I I just
wanted to clarify further and I I
certainly take the uh take the
representative at a word as to what the
intent of this is but my view is that in
order to accomplish what the stated
intent of this is line 12 would need to
read School personnel and shall not be
the sole basis for civil liability nor
the sole basis for employment action but
as
written I I would assume somewhere in
the code of conduct there's a
Prohibition on you know for instance
assaulting students and as written if a
teacher assaulted a student because it's
a violation of the code of conduct it
would appear that this would provide
them total civil liabil uh immunity in
such a
case so represent
Damon thank you Mr chair I was going to
make this remark anyway and I think it's
particularly relevant following what
representative Bel just said
this bill this amendment is specific
to
19340 and if you read carefully 19340
Roman numeral 4 it says violation of
this section it is only talking about
the code of conduct relative to this
section it is not the code of conduct in
its entirety for everything that it
covers
this okay I'm going to take a motion
right now I'm going to take a motion
from representative
belard thank you Mr chair I I would move
to um to itl on this amendment well we
don't have a we need a motion on the
bill apologies I would move to I on the
bill is there a second second we have a
motion on the floor to itl 1671 made by
representative beler and SE by
representative Cordell
per Bel would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chair and and
moving to the bill rather than the
amendment that we were just discussing
one of the one of the biggest problems I
see with this bill is that currently we
already in New Hampshire law both in
both civil and criminal statute have law
for defamation if somebody has their
character defamed if they're accused of
something they didn't do you can you can
go to court they can even be criminally
charged under the law but what it that
this bill would do is it would totally
create a different mechanism for
somebody to Sue and receive damage is
based on something that does not rise to
anywhere near the level of proof
necessary for defamation based solely on
the findings of a Schoolboard hearing it
would totally turn our system of justice
regarding defamation upside down and
create a culture of uh fear to report
any possible wrongdoing by you you know
coming from the public and I I think
that would be
wrong Is there further discussion on on
the motion the motion is to itl further
discussion repres
cordelli thank you I I agree with the U
uh the maker of the motion on the itl
motion uh but I'd also like to point out
that we've had discussion about this
with the previous Bill last week uh and
this
um uh bill in lines 8 88 and N in the
original bill um puts reflects current
Statute in that a school board decision
may be appealed to the State Board of
Education whereas in other legislation
we prohibit appeal excuse me um that we
can't um uh appeal to the state board so
I I just find um contradictions very
interesting further
discussion represent Miler yeah I think
it's important here um to note the
intent of the original
teachers are
subject uh to frivolous claims by
parents at times and I think the intent
of this bill was to provide some kind of
a
balance between being
subject um to public accusal by a parent
Visa some sense of balance that a
teacher has some right to also provide
some cross claim here I think that was
the original intent of the bill here now
not withstanding the discussion that
we've had on here and some issues around
the code of ethics and the code of
conduct but I think it's important to
note that that original intent was made
to provide some protection for the
instructor in the classroom to make sure
sure that there is no frivolous kind or
there is an there is an option to
respond uh to a frivolous uh attempt on
person and I'd like to just read one
point regarding the conduct uh code of
conduct it's Ed
50101 it's the purpose the purpose of a
code of conduct item D specify
unprofessional conduct which justifies
discipl disciplinary sanctions against
credential holders that's what this
section of law is all about or of the
code and I I think it's important to
keep it as it is written and with the
liability and all that left on the other
side with the code of ethics uh we're
mixing apples and oranges here and it
was when it was put together by
Educators they said the code of ethics
and code of conduct both separate thank
you further action or discussion on the
bill the motion is itl madam clerk
role Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Terry yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
represenative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner
no representative Luna yes
representative Heath yes Representative
wock no representative Hall yes
cascaden
motion
confused representative Lane is yes yes
yes that's what okay um C representative
cascaden yes representative Damon no
chairman lad yes can I change my vote
please
the G has not come down yet so we'll
no and oh chairman L already okay what's
the final 16 y four knees okay we're
going to close the hearing on
1671 there would be a Minority Report
represent
tner and was that 16 to four was that
count
beler send me your your I know you
already got it done before we even talk
thank
well both clocks are exactly the
same one's working and one's not working
once every 24 hours Broken yeah broken
clock is right
every twice every yeah well that's y
1382 was yes that when we had discussed
that's the special education support for
military compact students 13
information yes there was an email that
computer oh we um they were working on
uh language from other states I don't
think we've gotten all of it yeah I I
did see that language it came in by way
of uh email to us
and I I do have some concerns about how
they're wording their email they're
saying there has to be an
IEP evaluation within 30 days of the
student arriving that's not going to be
so if the school receiving School
accepts that IEP and the IEP is
current you wouldn't have to have an
evaluation you could have an an
intervention meeting to move forward
with the current IEP you don't have to
go through all the testing testing
measurements
again so I I do have a concern about the
way that's been worded in other states I
can remember when we put the compact
together there were a number areas
within which we did not agree with
everything that was in the compact we
definitely agreed with the whole
intent and and where it was going but it
didn't measure to the way we did things
in New Hampshire in terms of special
education services you got to remember
in in New Hampshire we have special
education law that supports idea but we
go further than it in in some
cases and so we reflected that time what
we are doing here as as our best
practice represent
leus a suggestion was made to use review
rather than evaluation because with a
review you don't have to do all of the
testing and all of that you just have to
look at it and say yes this still I I
would suggest that we get that email
disseminate it and hold this we don't
have to take action today on but there
is some some concern there there's part
of it which is fine the latter part of
that bill where there's responsibility
for if a parent wins a suit or whatever
the the fees are paid by Doe I have no
objections with that but I do have some
concerns about how we do it with how we
uh function in accordance with idea and
our state rule regul rules uh in law so
I want to make sure we're conforming to
what New Hampshire does not necessarily
what New York state does Mr chair yes Mr
chair is it possible is it possible to
get somebody from the Department here
that might be able to work with us and
answer this question yes I I mean there
there's a potential I'm surprised
nobody's here because there's a
potential liability here on the part of
the department for witness uh you know
for cost here and would seem to me that
it'd be good to have somebody here that
can answer the content of this as well
as the potential liability
here I think that's appropriate and I
think what we'll also do is we'll put
this off when we're doing some of the
exec of the other bills in
March and I will when I'm over there I
will talk to director fet on Friday when
I'm over there and I'll explain what's
going on and I will also take the email
that we got from I'll make sure that's
forwarded everybody on the committee
here thank
you so I I my suggestion is that we we
not take any action on that today is
there concurrence from the committee on
that thank
you we have any other bills no we going
this
14 what was it you said
1014 yeah okay we also want to discuss
1014 this is the voter
registration um in high school for the
high school
1014 I I I believe that I had the letter
which was from d scandin and
oh that let's get that out to everybody
so they can all read and what what uh is
bud
the other one the first shorter letter
comes from uh Secretary of State scandin
and the longer one comes from the
pitch
and4
so
Mr um yeah I got my original copy I did
not take one oh there there may be some
on the other side
okay
you have to go
now okay right right now we're just
doing a discussion so this is discussion
now okay just uh look at the first uh uh
long letter the one that was written by
um I got two Yeah by Mr pitch um he's
the general counsel assist assistant
Secretary of State um in that first
paragraph uh on the second line it say
everything that you're going to do in
terms of registration must conduct it in
accordance with New Hampshire law
obviously that's so in the second
paragraph down
there it it says about oh Midway through
on the right hand side in
addition to the Constitutional
obligation to provide equal treatment to
similarly situated in individuals it is
present a reality that political
officials need to consider whether
serving one group of Voters or
applicants different from another will
be perceived as having a
partisan
bias and the concern there is if you're
in a receiving high school and you have
kids coming from different school
districts at that high school and you
provideed for one group with the
supervisor checklist coming in that
represents the town from which they're
from or the clerk comes in and but you
don't do it for the other towns that is
um discrimination basically where you're
you're discriminating and you're
offering this service to
one but not to the
whole that's how I read that particular
you may read it
differently um Mr chair yes Mr chair
which letter were were you just
referring to the long one the one
requested by Mr
Bourne yeah
back in March of2 that was uh written by
Bud Fitch yes so so just a just a
question um was the response from from
um from Council Fitch
of of
1014 is that what we're talking about
yeah 1014 or was it directed to another
question
I would have to a ask him that I think
he's dealing with the issue the issue of
registering students at the school right
but 1014 doesn't doesn't address that
issue I mean I'm just trying to try to
understand if now there there's other
ways of getting around what we're
talking about and you know as being a
member of the task force which is
dealing with Civics education would oven
L montain sharing that they're very
interested in C education and and we
last year as you recall we passed a bill
in the house senate and signed in the
law that there's acquired course a half
your course in Civics at the middle
school level and then again at the high
school
level they see this as something that
can be very much integrated into that
instruction as far as you you as a a a
Civics teacher I would certainly want to
invite somebody from the local community
to come in be it the a person from the
supervisor checklist or the clerk or
somebody else from the town to come in
and explain the process that we have in
place here in the state for register how
to register to to vote and that it's the
responsibility of everybody to to vote
um that's important and that could be
done quite easily you could have folks
come in just as you have many other
people invited to come into the into the
classroom
um there there's some cautions here um
though that that I I think that need to
be addressed even though it may not be
written specifically to this bill I
think it also says that you know we're
going to treat all the students with
equal
opportunity then the other one from M uh
uh Mr
scanland
um and it just addressed the issue that
you cannot you cannot take form formal
action to accept that any kind of a
application for registration at the
school it has to be done by the voter
that by committee back at the municipal
building and that it says a single
supervisor attending an event to receive
applications that will not be acted on
till a subsequent supervisor sessions is
not a public meeting of the board
therefore public notice and act access
to the event are not required so if one
person's going to a school you don't
have to have public notice because it's
not the meeting where they approve these
applications for voting that's done back
at the town office I think that's what
they're trying to clarify in Mr scandin
letter represent whitcock thank you
chair I would agree with you
particularly in the last paragraph
because under the board director of the
board of supervisor so if you put from
uh secretary scallan's letter on three
and four those two paragraphs it was see
to me that that is applicable and
allowable for a high school to hold the
event for example if Miss hether
supervisor at the author of event she
would take the applications back to the
regular board for final uh blessing if I
read
that right but the other one I'm saying
if if there are other students at a
school that don't come underneath this
that that particular Town yeah but we're
not sure that this repres L's point was
valid we're not sure that this
March 2223 letter is addressing
1617 at4 but we do know the the
Secretary of sc's letter is addressing
1014 and it says it's okay long as the
board of the board of regist supervis
depend which title they use does it
that's how I read that well read the
last sentence there in paragraph three
that's addressed to Mr
Bourne it says if it is the case that a
high school age student students from
any of the involved towns go to
different high schools and the in-person
voter registration is offered at only
one the supervisors need to consider
this issue there are some issues that
need to be looked at in terms fairness
that's the supervisor that's not that's
not the you would think the school would
look at it too though they may but it's
clear that the supervisor is going to be
there that's the whole point of the
letter of of 2020 April
18th Mr Sheriff yes represent Amon
there's an amendment upstairs that would
potentially address some of these
concerns I thought another person was
bringing the copies forward may I go get
yes m m Mr chair
okay and the motion is Mr Corell I think
it's important that we know what the
letter that Mr Bourne wrote to the
attorney J it says for those reasons it
appears unlikely that we can provide a
letter with the terms you seek we don't
know what Mr waren was asking right of
the of the Secretary of State's office
it just we don't know what he's
answering well if you look in the last
paragraph from uh B Fitch you can see
he's really clarifying information as
far
as Firearms po policy if you're going to
do this some schools may not even allow
that to occur
but we don't know what terms he's asking
about I mean this goes from supervisors
for a different students from different
towns that attend to school to Firearms
to I I don't know what Mr borne was
asking the answer CH well the first
sentence absolutely says it thank you uh
for your efforts encouraging voter
registration okay so this letter is
addressing issues associated with voter
registration at
schools secondary schools yes
schoolid the Town eligible register to
attend that school obligate provide to
other out of school yeah that's what
we're talking about represent culture
thank you Mr I just had a procedural
question I wanted to clarify have we
taking up a bill yet or are we just
discussing we're discussing we're
discussing yeah M
yes go ahead it's if it's all right I
mean this may this may be a larger
Pandora's Box and we would think that
this simple bill would deal with because
I've been informed that we already have
schools that are uh registering students
so uh in schools and so if some schools
you talk about discrimination if some
schools are in fact already doing that
and others don't have an opportunity to
do that uh you know then that could be a
problem and I and I think representative
Lane also is is on the uh election law
uh committee and I'm assuming that this
would also fall in the purview of that
particular committee um yes we were
surprised that we didn't get it but um I
can tell you that and to confirm that
some some schools I mean some towns and
cities or municipalities have go in and
register students already they do yeah
we we do know that's occurring and
that's a local decision that can be done
in conjunction with your Civics
curriculum it can be done in conjunction
of a Cooperative agreement with the
municipality and the schools um the the
questions that the question I'm raising
is that we have a number of high schools
that receive students from different
municipalities
and where one municipality may be doing
this and another may not then you get in
in your registering at that High
School we're not open this is uh a
service that's being provided for some
students but not all the students within
that school it's different than if
you're going to a district which is in
the same municipality like like a
Manchester well Manchester may even have
some kids coming in
tuition Mr Mr chair yes yeah so so thank
you the the um you know it's obviously
it's it's it's clear from the date on
the two letters that that the letters
were um preceded the introduction of uh
the bill we're talking about right now
so neither of these letters could have
contemplated um House Bill 1014 but
House Bill 1014 basically basically
directs school districts and private
high and private high schools to adopt
policies that um that contain two things
one informing students U of state
requirements for voter registration and
B providing access to and assistance
with um filing registration applications
I don't mean but I have a point of order
on this um I I don't believe we there
was any advertisement for any sort of a
work session on this bill I think
technically to be in compliance we have
to take a motion on this before we can
do all of this I often times have had
discussion and we use it also as a
discussion opportunity for us when we
are executing bills to to have a sense
of where we're going sometimes it's come
out that we can come out with a simple
tweak and then come back with an
amendment that's proper and would the
number of bills this is different than
many of the Committees in this house we
have 107 bills we've had some work
sessions on for other bills we're going
to have some training on the Cooperative
School District stuff but that's about
all the time we've had so this is why I
make this exception where we can have
discussion that's been a common
denominator here for years even when I
wasn't sharing this this particular
group so Mr chair if I could if I could
finish my my my remarks mhm um so so NE
neither letter appears to be because of
the their dates appear to be directed at
the bill where at 10:14 that we're
talking about um uh right now and uh and
all the Bill calls for is for schools um
uh school districts and private high
schools to adopt policies with respect
to um to informing students uh of
requirements for voter registration and
providing access policies for providing
access to and assistance with filing uh
registration applications and and and
clearly the secretary clearly the
legislature has has already established
standards for um you know through I'm
I'm sure through its election law
committee committees that um uh that
apply to uh to voter registration
non-coercion stuff like that and uh and
we also have the the guidance from the
Secretary of State's office with respect
to how these policies might um uh might
impact multi- municipality school
districts and and private schools you
know we also have the School Board
Association that uh that creates um Mo
draft policies that school districts
could adopt and this I would imagine
would would become uh one of those and
uh and would be informed not just by by
House Bill 1014 not just by the Four
Corners of House Bill 1014 but by other
laws that are in force right now with
respect to uh to voter registration so
so I I I think I guess what I'm saying
is is I think the two the two letters
are good background information um
there's probably other state laws that
are also good good information to inform
what those policies are going to be but
it's but uh but 1014 is really um is
really a fairness uh uh type of Bill I
think representative Myer hit it that uh
that some schools were already doing
this but not all schools and uh and to
be fair for all
165,000 um uh students that are in
public school districts plus another
15,000 students that attend private
schools in New Hampshire that uh that
they that they each you know receive
some um um some instruction in uh in
this area and I I agree that I think
that could be done as the chair was
suggesting POS possibly through Civics
curriculum too and there's nothing in in
1014 that that directs it to be done one
way or the other way or inside or
outside Civics curriculum but but uh but
that would make a lot sense I I I get
what you're saying but my concern is I
guess on the first line of all the
Amendments including the
bill each School District
shall that's not the way it's working in
our state right now we've heard people
discuss earlier here that local
districts might be doing this some are
doing some are not doing it why do we
have to mandate this
Sher in each district and private high
school it says they shall have policies
yeah shall have
policies
why uh wait a minute wait a minute we're
going to tell a private school that
they're going to have to have a policy
on this when in the private school
holderness school they're coming from
place can we have representative Pell
thank you I two points
um I forgot the first one second second
one under RSA 18922 and R 18923 this is
already required um 8922 says the
secretary of state is hereby directed to
furnish to the State Board of Education
such number number of copies of the
State Constitution and election laws as
may be necessary and 23 says the State
Board of Education is hereby directed to
distribute copies of the State
Constitution and election laws to all
teachers of history and Civics in the
upper grades of elementary schools and
to teachers of the United of US history
and Junior and senior high schools to be
used by them in instructing their pupils
relative to the laws governing election
and voting these two chapters are from
1937 mhm yep represent cordelli and then
we're going to have a motion uh thank
you and thank you for uh finding those
sections because I've been looking for
them and I haven't been able to find
them but um that came up in a prior
discussion on a prior bill and I checked
with the uh chair of the State Board of
Education and the commissioner and uh
they said oh gosh this dates back to the
1930s we don't think this is being done
but we will start do it uh to make that
information
available yes representative Pam I would
add that representative dry myself and
another representative had legislation
to um fund the distribution of these
copies because it was something that
wasn't being done and we know it's not
years Dam com on well what we're going
to do is we're going to have a caucus
right now brief caucus and then we will
come back take action and then um have
lunch because I think we're I think
we're pretty much done our bills right
now so this is the last one so let's
have let's have some time here for a
brief caucus and and we'll come
yeah
time myen I may do that
too
notes fiscal what makes an early Bill if
$10,000 learn something learning
something
new what' you learn
today yep I should give you the cliff
notes of course my family would not be
will be very underwhelmed by that
mean
here
e
yeah we're reconvening the executive
sessions today and we also closing down
the executive sessions for today and
much